going back to that theoretical dinner
let's suppose the buffer the social
buffer is gone now it's filmmaker and
the one with the checkbook right what
should that filmmaker do with good
intention with integrity to make sure
that they know this person with the cash
knows that they may never see it again
um why I think you have a moral
obligation to make sure it's not the
rent money or the mortgage money you
know like you don't want to be sitting
there's no nestling money from little
old ladies that they can't no paper buy
groceries make sure someone who has I
mean that's always that's always easy
this s out is make sure this is this is
fun money for them and and that cause
here for a while but I don't know you
have so need to bring it up if they
bring it up of course you say hey
absolutely but you always have an
investment packet where you have all
information and you kind of have that
disclaimer in there and saying you know
what they are better investments than
indie film if you want to you know if
you want to really invest your money
well put it in commercial real estate or
invest in one ingredient in the xanax
you know there was a company called Galt
it was the largest private investment
group of the room still may need a
largest private I don't know but they
they fell in love with filmmaking for a
while because they owned again like one
ingredient in like these major
subscription or prescriptions so they
every time someone bought xanax or
whatever it was or you know I'm valium
or something yeah whatever they would
they would make a penny and know
Brazilians up so they were just making
hand over fist mine Gilly of the dollars
were coming in and they found that they
went to parties or bars they say yeah I
oem's annex people go whatever you know
oh no far on pharmaceutical ingredients
100 carats then they said it to get into
filmmaking into district in the
distribution actually on the open of a
label just because it was a felt it was
a passive business they could pick a
movie for nothing and spit it out but
then they started going to parties and
saying yeah I distribute movies you
distribute movies Wow and then became a
much more attractive thing so they kind
of fell in love with it simply for that
reason I think it's what you always go
back to is them they say well you know
ah i'll make sure i get a return on my
investment and say well
unfortunately University of the Arts the
you know the financial investment can
take time to happen or may never happen
how may be partial you know you make the
terms as favorable as you want the deal
we have it so you get one hundred twenty
percent of your investment back before
we see a dime but you always say is that
really why you're investing you know
bring it back to the fun bring it back
to the fact this is going to be an
adventure you get to go on set you get
to hang out at parties you know film
festivals and all these things and you
can be part of the fun we have an exec
producer in favor to put in some money
and she is she was going to get back or
it would be a long time but she she you
know she loved the script and she you
know love Patrick and huge advocate for
us T is still an involved she's gotten
very involved in the film and she came
down to Q days and she started putting
money into other films because she
really just likes the dream she's like I
rather be a patron of the yard you can't
get these films made and go see these
things in front of audiences and just
enjoy enabling artists then you know
worrying about whether I get a return of
my you know a few thousand dollars it's
not investing big sums of money but but
I mean it's definitely helpful sure
you